why do you feel that now is the right
time in your career to take this leap of
faith and join the celebrity big brother
world
well i just did the math singer i had a
small break and there was a pocket of
time that i had right before i went on
tour
and i just don't think that it's a
coincidence that it perfectly fit into
that time period um i'm such a huge fan
of the show and immediately
when they posted it and julie chen said
that there was going to be a celebrity
season probably 20 to 50 of my friends
sent me the post because everyone knows
how much i love it it felt like kismet
it felt like it was the right time and
um i and
i don't know i just
i feel like fate wants me to be there
and i think that i prepared my whole
life for a show like this so
it was something i couldn't turn down
now as a celebrity you're accustomed to
people watching your every move and
living under a microscope are you ready
for the public to see you in a different
light watching you 24 7
i think two years ago i would not have
been because i used to be really really
affected by the rumors and evil things
that i see people say on twitter and
social media and my comments etc
but now i'm just in a much better place
and i'm really more focusing on the
people who are for me the people who do
support me the people who are on my back
the people who are inspired by my music
and my message and so i'm doing this for
them i don't think it's possible in 2022
to go into a house and be filmed
24 7 and not say something that will
offend someone but um i think that the
people who
who support me who love me will always
see my heart um i think that's the sad
thing about living in 2022 as a public
figure is that you're expected to not
make mistakes and to not be a human
basically like without making mistakes
you're no longer a human you're a robot
and i don't want to be a robot so i'm
down to make mistakes and i'm okay with
the fact that if i follow my face there
will maybe be negative criticism i'm not
gonna let it [ __ ] me and i'm not
gonna let it stand in the way of amazing
opportunities that come my way
fantastic outlook
what part of yourself are you most
scared or embarrassed for the public to
see so this can be something fun like um
no glam or being grumpy in the morning
um i don't know i think that i have
catfished the world into thinking i'm a
lot more fabulous than i am and i don't
actually do makeup i can't do my own
makeup i wear sweatpants every single
day i usually don't wash my clothes i
don't even know how to use a washing
machine or a dryer so i'm really worried
about myself and how it what i'm what
i'm going to look like and i also like
love love love to scratch my toes with
my socks at the end of every night it's
like my nightly ritual
and i just feel like people are gonna
see that and maybe be grossed out but i
i feel like that's the thing i'm the
most nervous for people to see
who would you not want to see walk
through the doors of the celebrity big
brother house
there are some people who i used to be
close friends with who i'm not friends
with anymore and i think those would be
the only people i wouldn't want to see
walk through the door but
i don't think that i hate anybody enough
that i wouldn't be able to put our
differences aside and work with them
everybody who i hate
anybody who i have um negative feelings
towards is somebody that at some point
in my life i loved very much which is
the reason why i feel so strongly about
them so it could possibly be a blessing
in disguise to have somebody like that
walk through the door
you